Before we jump into R,
let's understand the data.
Each entry of this
data set corresponds
to a census tract, a statistical
division of the area that
is used by researchers to
break down towns and cities.
As a result, there will usually
be multiple census tracts
per town.
LON and LAT are the
longitude and latitude
of the center of
the census tract.
MEDV is the median value of
owner-occupied homes, measured
in thousands of dollars.
CRIM is the per
capita crime rate.
ZN is related to
how much of the land
is zoned for large
residential properties.
INDUS is the proportion of
the area used for industry.
CHAS is 1 if a census tract
is next to the Charles
River, which I drew before.
NOX is the concentration
of nitrous oxides
in the air, a measure
of air pollution.
RM is the average number
of rooms per dwelling.
AGE is the proportion
of owner-occupied units
built before 1940.
DIS is a measure of
how far the tract is
from centers of
employment in Boston.
RAD is a measure of closeness
to important highways.
TAX is the property tax
per $10,000 of value.
And PTRATIO is the pupil
to teacher ratio by town.
Let's switch over to R now.
So let's begin to analyze our
data set with R. First of all,
we'll load the data set
into the Boston variable.
If we look at the structure
of the Boston data set,
we can see all the variables
we talked about before.
There are 506
observations corresponding
to 506 census tracts in
the Greater Boston area.
We are interested in
building a model initially
of how prices vary by
location across a region.
So let's first see how
the points are laid out.
Using the plot commands, we can
plot the latitude and longitude
of each of our census tracts.
This picture might be a
little bit meaningless to you
if you're not familiar with
the Massachusetts-Boston area,
but I can tell you that the
dense central core of points
corresponds to Boston
city, Cambridge
city, and other
close urban cities.
Still, let's try and relate
it back to that picture
we saw in the first video,
where I showed you the river
and where MIT was.
So we want to show all
the points that lie along
the Charles River in
a different color.
We have a variable,
CHAS, that tells us
if a point is on the
Charles River or not.
So to put points on an
already-existing plot,
we can use the
points command, which
looks very similar
to the plot command,
except it operates in a
plot that already exists.
So let's plot just the points
where the Charles River
variable is set to one.
Up to now it looks pretty
much like the plot command,
but here's where it's
about to get interesting.
We can pass a
color, such as blue,
to plot all these
points in blue.
And this would plot
blue hollow circles
on top of the black
hollow circles.
Which would look
all right, but I
think I'd much prefer
to have solid blue dots.
To control how the
points are plotted,
we use a PCH option, which you
can read about more in the help
documentation for
the points command.
But I'm going to
use PCH 19, which
is a solid version of the dots
we already have on our plot.
So by running this
command, you see
we have some blue
dots in our plot now.
These are the census tracts that
lie along the Charles River.
But maybe it's still a
little bit confusing,
and you'd like to know where
MIT is in this picture.
So we can do that too.
I looked up which
census tract MIT is in,
and it's census tract 3531.
So let's plot that.
We add another point,
the longitude of MIT,
which is in tract 3531,
and the latitude of MIT,
which is in census tract 3531.
I'm going to plot
this one in red,
so we can tell it apart from
the other Charles River dots.
And again, I'm going to
use a solid dot to do it.
Can you see it on
the little picture?
This little red dot,
right in the middle.
That's exactly what
we were looking
at from the picture in Video One
What other things can we do?
Well, this data set was
originally constructed
to investigate
questions about how
air pollution affects prices.
So the air pollution variable
is this NOX variable.
Let's have a look at
a distribution of NOX.
boston$NOX.
So we see that the
minimum value is 0.385,
the maximum value is
0.87 and the median
and the mean are
about 0.53, 0.55.
So let's just use
the value of 0.55,
it's kind of in the middle.
And we'll look at
just the census
tracts that have
above-average pollution.
So we'll use the
points command again
to plot just those points.
So, points, the latitude--no
the longitude first.
So we want the census
tracts with NOX levels
greater than or equal to 0.55.
We want the latitude of
those same census tracks.
Again, only if the NOX
is greater than 0.55.
And I guess a suitable
color for nasty pollution
would be a bright green.
And again, we'll
use the solid dots.
So you can see it is pretty much
the same as the other commands.
Wow okay.
So those are all the points have
got above-average pollution.
Looks like my office
is right in the middle.
Now it kind of
makes sense, though,
because that's the dense
urban core of Boston.
If you think of anywhere
where pollution would be,
you'd think it'd be where the
most cars and the most people
are.
So that's kind of interesting.
Now, before we do
anything more, we
should probably look at how
prices vary over the area
as well.
So let's make a new plot.
This one's got a few
too many things on it.
So we'll just plot
again the longitude
and the latitude for
all census tracts.
That kind of resets our plot.
If we look at the distribution
of the housing prices (Boston
MEDV), we see that
the minimum price
(remember units are
thousands of dollars,
so the median value of
owner-occupied homes
is in thousands of
dollars) is around five,
the maximum is around 50.
So let's plot again only the
above-average price points.
So we'll go:
points(boston$LON[boston$MEDV>=21.2].
We can also plot the latitude:
boston$LATboston$LAT[boston$MEDV>=21.2].
We'll reuse that red
color we used for MIT.
And one more time, with
we'll do the solid dots.
So what we see now are
all the census tracts
with above-average
housing prices.
As you can see, it's
definitely not simple.
There's census tracts of
above-average and below-average
mixed in between each other.
But there are some patterns.
For example, look at that
dense black bit in the middle.
That corresponds to most
of the city of Boston,
especially the southern
parts of the city.
Also, on the Cambridge
side of the river,
there's a big chunk there
of dots that are black,
that are not red, that are
also presumably below average.
So there's definitely
some structure to it,
but it's certainly
not simple in relation
to latitude and
longitude at least.
We will explore this
more in the next video.